thank you so this is a drawing work with
my postdoc being challenged and actually
most of the ideas came from him the
motivation is are in disk arrays are
subject to different types of failures
in particular a disarray will subject
you will be subject to device failure
where you lose all your data in the disk
or it may be the center area or some
people call this the latent Center
errors where you will lose the data in
one particular Center so there'll of
measurement studies showing that these
type of failures are very common in real
life so the Left figure shows the end of
this video ray collected from the Google
Data Center so it finds that actually
the this video rays could reach up to
ten percent which is a lot if you
consider that in a large scale system
they are Loftus now the middle figured
talks about the set of failures
basically what it shows is the set of
failure rate is much higher than the
disk failure rate so the set of theories
are actually more common to be found in
real life and the right thinker
basically shows that the set of failure
patterns actually could come in a burst
it's not very car it's not very frequent
but it's still possible so the question
is how do we protect against this device
videos and also the set of videos and
become an approach is to apply erasure
coding here we consider the NK
systematic MDS codes basically it can be
summarized as what we try to encode k
data symbols into n minus K additional
symbols which we call the parodies and
then we have n symbols which we call a
stripe and disabilities are n symbols
across the disk and any K of n symbols
can reconstruct the original k data
symbols or input in other words as long
as you have k symbols then you can
reconstruct all the ends and books you
can think of this symbol as one bite but
typically when we apply to this arrays
you'll be mapped to dis set asides could
be like 512 bytes or maybe some
kilobytes what we do is we encode it
in both repeatedly so you can think of
actually the symbol could be directly
map two scepters andreas just one
specific implementation of the original
coding for example r85 you can't I
really want this failure and races you
can tolerate through this video's the
question is given that the disarray
would be subject to our dis failures and
set of failures so how do we apply your
razor coding in this scenario so let's
consider a worst-case failure scenario
is an example let's say there could be
at most M equals to one entirely parody
our entire entirely failed device and in
addition to that there could be M prime
equals to do partially fail devices
where you don't lose all your data in
those devices but you lose some of your
data and in those two parity failure
devices that could be one or three set
of failures and most here we consider a
strike okay so so within a stripe are
there could be one and three set of
thetas in these M prime possibly
favorite advisors so the question is how
do we design the erasure code the guitar
is such a mixed failure scenario now
let's consider a traditional approach
which is used by rate actually what it
does is it doesn't consider whether it's
a device failure or set of a tease it
just considered that the whole device
fails okay so what it does is it would
just simply allocate three parity
devices to tolerate both the and highly
favored device and depository filled
devices which is actually the motivation
when people are design race sex because
out they find that in this array not
only you have one fail device but in
addition to that you can have some bait
and center error so that's why they come
up with race sex to tolerate to device
failures but that actually is an over Q
because right now you use to parity
devices to tolerate to passively failure
devices may be at any point of time you
just lose one Center at most but you use
the whole parity device to protect in
such one set of failure now if we
consider that
right now we start a lot of beta that is
there's quite a lot of storage
redundancy or that's there's a huge
overhead and the observation is that in
rate or many traditional erasure coding
actually they just assume the device
level for tourists they don't consider
the next video scenario you mean sector
what is part so the device has some some
lost data some some set of failures well
in entirely fair device you lose all
your data in the disk so that this could
have but how does it make a difference
we will come to that baby so it means
extra fee yeah right okay but the thing
okay that's my mask doesn't mean sector
yeah so another approach is our we
allocate are some parity setters per
device and this is the approach taken by
this what they call the eye dr approach
because right now in our scenario are
the worst cases that would be free set
of failures so what it does is it just
assumed the worst case and in each
device you allocate three parity
searches and also you have one parity
device to tal ready and highly fill disk
and in this case you can see that
actually is very expensive because right
now you add parity setters per data
device and the observation here is that
these parity centers only take care of
its own device but are but among across
these devices they're independent but so
these are three out of how many sectors
uh it depends on the number of rows that
you considered right now we consider 16
yeah so actually how big you are this
sector is generally typically is 512
bytes but you could be like one cube IM
for cube by but it's on the KP scale
yeah so uh so the reason work came up
with a code called SD code and what they
want to do is to design a code that can
tolerate simultaneously the M and highly
favored devices and in addition to that
s fail centers / stripe in those parts
of the very devices so here this is the
stripe how the scribe looks like so you
have em parity devices and in addition
to that you have as priority status so
what that means is let's say you have
the device fails and yet in addition to
that and the S set of failures have it
in this stripe so they can still be
protected by these asperity searches and
the current are currently the
construction will be limited to as less
than or equal to 3 i'll explain a little
bit why why is the case in a moment so
the question is now go back two hours in
our worst-case scenario what what should
we do if we want you yep so I relating
to ashish talk if I just put put all
these green things in a big line one
after the other it seems you want to
correct one group of four and any extra
three that is stronger than what you're
doing right that would work for you
right yeah yeah but but there's a
there's a huge overhead I mean the shoe
Java involve collecting collecting any
set of six right so 11 definite so it
stuck all the green boxes in one big
line now one thing you can say is any
set of six I control it okay
then you can do with a little knowledge
huge overhead but he does better than
that right because he doesn't do any set
of six he does n is any 14 consecutive
ones plus 3 Armitage yeah this is even
more restricted echoes yeah this is not
any set of four this is it is given in
the book and the book thoughts of it
looks at specific whereas his blob can
be arbitrary yeah if I are you doing
what's on the skimming issues you're
doing like let's say three random
variations for us one phone call right
right right right right so is this
related to the rise okay so um let's
give you this the question is let's say
right now F and most for set of failures
so in this case we will need to dedicate
for parity centers we call that the
global because you can protect any set
of videos within the strike now turns
out that such a construction is
unavailable now okay here come to users
here here come to users the first issue
is why it's not available maybe you just
simply take all these grin Sacha's as
the data symbols and use MDS code to
construct the remaining rats and those
as the parity symbols then in this case
is an MDS code you can you can tolerate
any s number of set of faders it worse
but the thing is the overhead will be
very huge because right now whenever you
for example you do the encoding you need
you to collect all these green symbols
to ankle ordered party symbols and when
you do the decoding let's say you lose
11 center here you need to collect the
other ceteris or the parity centers so
as to reconstruct this our parity center
then from the implementation perspective
the overhead will be huge it depends on
the number of rows
your advocate you say overhead you don't
necessarily mean coding rate you mean
computational complexity nice yeah
exactly so here we put a requirement
which are first which is very similar to
rate is this parity device will be just
generated by the data symbols of the
same bro so for example this one I want
to just generate disparity using the
same row of data symbols to generate
this one and and for the other one they
also generated by the data symbols of
the same row and only for these parity
centers that will be generated by other
data centers within the strike so that's
why because of this constraint are the
SD code is only limited to s echoed less
than or equal to three and if when they
come up with the code is very different
from the traditional approach of you
have an encoding matrix you multiply
this matrix with the factor of data
single and generate the parity symbols
and what they do is they need to come up
with some algebraic equations and try to
exhaustively search for the solution
space which is a very different from the
traditional coding approach so so that's
why they cannot find this for as greater
than three and that that that's the
limitation so what we want to do is can
we come up with another code that are
take this as come straight away she says
what it says with your constraints of
the feed sense we didn't consider that
just are because later on we just build
on existing MDS code so i think they
considered few size are one bite to buy
some four bys in SD code but here we
just consider one by us as the
so that's why we came up with the stank
oh and we want to consider eight general
and space efficient code and by general
what that means is it has no limitation
on the size of the storage array and and
the number of terrible device radius
which is M and the number of terrible
set of videos and also by space
efficiency what that means is our we
want to just use the parity centers to
tourists at the failures to slice SD
code instead of using the whole parity
device because we call this tech hole
and later we will see the reason so we
consider the failure scenario is a test
like the rate if you have empties
failures you just use the railway
construction to weaken certain approach
to just rebuild the end this devices and
for the furtherance we consider the
worst case where m displayed is and also
the coverage of set of videos which we
will define the coverage in in a moment
now one thing is this code we didn't
consider the repair performance so what
that means is if you have a one failed
device you still read the amount for
original data so we didn't consider the
repair performance in our work but in
this work but but later in future work
we'll talk about that in distributed
storage system which would cover at the
end of the talk so uh so the idea is are
we want to make a general so we need to
get some trade off Oh makes me some
trade-offs so why is the tray of here so
in SD code you can tolerate any number
of set of failures within a stripe now
here instead of targeting any number of
said are any number of set of alias we
now define a pattern of how the set of
failures occur in stuff how many set of
failures occur so if you are able to
define this coverage what we call it a
set of failure coverage factor then
basically
thing will be very straightforward and
you can simply build a code using the
existing MDS code and we find out we use
this approach to come up with two
encoding methods up stand downstairs and
coding and they are complementary to
each other which I will show you how
they work so let's talk about what what
we mean by the set of failure coverage
factor so basically our is defined by a
factor of M Prime elements what it does
is it tries to bound the number of
devices that have set of ideas in
addition to the device failure so right
now let's say you wanted higher rate m
device radius ok now remaining we have n
minus M devices now within this n minus
M you can pick a number which is M prime
which could contain the set of videos so
so we assume that the different
operators can come up with this
parameter M Prime ok and we think these
possibly fail devices you bound the
number of set of failures per device
which is e l and the sum of this year
will be SS is equal to the number of set
of values that you can tolerate within a
strike and the rest now is if the set of
failures could come in bursts so what
you can do is you can define a small M
Prime and some reasonable size dl for
the burst so let me give you an example
back to our previous a scenario where I
want to tolerate these are two possibly
fail devices with one set of ABS and
three set of faders in the other device
so what we do is we can be design of
factor which is 13 what it means is any
two devices are you know besides these
and highly favored devices could have
set of areas where one device could have
a most free set of ages and another one
could have at most one set of Ages when
you put this fatter you have the
protection so basically this is how it
worse
and you can decide this er2 are to take
care of some special cases for example
if a equals to one that will be very
similar to that will be equivalent to
the PM disco and SD codes with s equal
to one if a equals two are basically are
you assume that one part of the favorite
device but all this our setters
considered to be fail actually it's just
equivalent to the entire leaf partially
filled advice sorry and highly favored
device so in this case it would be just
equivalent to this and animals and minus
one course and uh if e you put all the
absolutes well there will be n minus M
elements that will be you can furniture
the idea of course with our absolute
priority symbols so basically you can
come up with different ye and you you
can control the code accordingly now we
don't advocate any particular key so
that would be the future work what
should be the right knee when we
construct a code now suppose that we
know this e so the question is how do we
generate these parity sandals now what
we want to do is we want to have a
stripe where we have one parity device
and also we reserve some space to store
these are 13 global parity status and to
generate these global parity centers and
parity device what we do is we use to
MDS code 0 and C column we don't put any
restriction on this MDS code but here we
consider the culture Solomon codes
so what we do is we go through two
phases the first phase is we do it in a
row direction where you have the data
symbols in each row and you generate the
parities where you would generate the
parity devices and the additional
intermediate parities we don't store
this in the media priorities which will
be served as the input to the second
phase to generate the global parity
status now you can easily see that
actually these global parity centers can
protect the set of failure pattern that
we defined earlier for example let's say
you have one set of fail so in this case
are this will be you can consider as a
Eurasia but you have this parity symbol
to protect this so in this case you can
use this to reconstruct the loss lost
etc so in this case that that would work
now the question is where to restore
these global parity centers in general
you have to find somewhere to store
these global heritage edges so what we
do is we want to move that inside a
stripe and this is what we want to do
now given the data symbols as the input
you can generate the output which is the
global parity centers what we do is we
set these parodies centers as zeros and
try to are inversely find out what
should be the values of this global
Verity centers so given the data as
symbols and also the output will be
equal to zero I want to generate all
these parity setters as well as this
parity device so in this way I can
reconstruct the insight global parity
status so how do we do that and the idea
is we augment the stripe which we call
the canonical stripe such that we open
the row by encode this with our they see
column ok so to form the amanda rose and
you have some empty space which we call
the virtual parities and i want to
generate such virtual
parodies so as to we construct all these
parity sectors that actually store and
because of this in India property
actually each mentor role is actually a
cobra of the sero okay so this one
actually is a cover of the zero now how
do we generate this a red parity symbols
and let's take a one approach which is
the upstairs approach you can also see
that the parity layer is is is like a
step so that's why we call it is their
code and what we do is we try to follow
the upstair direction try to generate
all the possible symbols given the
available or symbols and you can also
generate this as the decoding approach a
thing of this as you lose some symbols
and you follow the same way to
reconstruct the lost symbol so let's
take a look at how this stair codes were
so what we do is we first pick the 0 and
C column in this example that will be 10
7 and 74 so any seven symbols you can
get all the ten symbols and for the
column direction any four symbols you
can get all the seven symbols now we
start with the leftmost column now
because right now we have four symbols
oh sorry so right now because we have
four symbols so you can generate or all
the other three in step one step two you
can generate the other three step three
step four and step 5 now you find that
right now in this particular row you
have are the five symbols that you just
generated as well as the zeros that you
assumed earlier so right now I can
generate the symbols for step 6 and step
7 because right now in this column I
have three Queens and bows which is of
which are available and also this one
you just generate this so that's why I
have are the other parities and you do
it alternately between the row and
column the Russian and you can generate
all these are parity symbols
and one thing is the parity computation
is based on the previous computer
parodies and we find that you will
improve the encoding performance the
downstairs the restaurant work in a very
similar way I won't go into the detail
but you can the main ideas are you do it
alternately to generate all these
symbols and these two and coding matters
would give you the same result okay you
would generate the same set of parity
symbols but the performance are
different performance in the sense that
the encoding the number of are a number
of multiplications that you need to do
and we do a lot of analysis since the
paper and the intuition is for large n
prime you should choose the upstairs and
coding for the downstairs and coding for
small M prize to choose the downstairs
encoding and the analysis and it's in
the paper so we do some evaluation are
the first evaluation years we look at
the space-saving and the x-axis is
different our or the number of rows per
strike and we take from 02 to 32 and why
is this number of devices that you store
basically if the rose is our is large on
basically you just use a small number of
parity setters instead of the whole
device so it will approach M prime if if
our increases so so that's intuitive
that one is compared to the traditional
great this is the encoding speed are we
implement the code and try to measure
the encoding performance what we find is
basically is very fast is on the order
of 1000 megabyte per second which is
much faster than the Iowa speed so we
believe that the encoding won't be the
bottleneck and compared with SD code
because we will use the parity so that's
why the performances is good
and the penalty here is the update cost
because right now when you update one
data same boat you also need to update
the not only the the parity symbol of
the same row but also the global
heritage and when you update the
variable parities you also a fat the
parity symbols of the same bro so that's
why the update cost will be higher than
traditional or original code that have
the same for tolerance and that's what
we see here but we think it should be
still okay if we consider system with
rare updates such as backups or those
with boots right price such as SSD and
actually we didn't consider the repair
in the earlier work but we find that
actually we can map the stereo in the
digital storage system so the idea is
right now for each row you can think of
this as a rack and each Center you can
map this to a note and what you can do
is if you are want to read let's say
with any new fail you can use the parity
of the same brag to reconstruct a loss
or loss of data and in this case you
don't do and you don't trigger any
crossref transfer which is very
important because in datacenter
crossbred bandwidth is very limited and
the big idea is you also want you not
only use these parity to improve the
repair performance but you can also use
this parity to tolerate the burst of the
failures within the rack and we find
that you can improve both the prepared
performance and also the storage
efficiency which is something we
consider but they're out there love
engineering work where we play in the
cut the file system unit you change the
scheduling which is something another
issue so I to conclude basically we
propose their code and have two
complementary and concluding matters and
the implementation is open source so we
can try it out and
um thank you I appreciate your questions
so I may have misunderstood something
but back to Lara's question it really
looks very much like work by could be
doing and rock from the 90s where they
were working the great systems as well
and they came up with these gabbi doolin
codes and they are using also MDS codes
in Ronnie's construction at least which
are the cold words are put on the
diagonals it looks a little bit like the
leader downstairs or upstairs cleaner
and as Laura pointed out there were
recent work where you can basically
figure out how to trade off disc versus
sector failure and you decide to call
the disk failure if you have a certain
threshold of error so you exceed a
certain number of errors you call it a
disk failure and if you have a smaller
number of errors you just concatenate
let's say subspace out in an MDS code
and i'm not sure if you have seen that
work and if because it seems related i
may be off but it seems very very
related or what's the name so the early
word go just Google gabbi doolin coats
you will say I can talk to you a little
bit later so I've didn't need distance
metrics that you are trying to achieve
with these constructions like for the
kind of failures you are looking at
maybe just the Hamming distance may not
be the right metrics median consider
just we assume the favor device and also
the theater it may be a last quick
question and we move on so I to make a
agent info most part but so you have
this class of codes and you showed it an
example of this one point
so how Daniel is the construction at all
I mean so why can't you do it SD codes I
mean why or can you do it can can you so
in your favor can you get an instance of
physical or some out of it 4 4 s equal
to 1 we can gain instance of SD co sto
is my bed who's the device and then you
have right on fire edition they are in
dec haste st cops doesn't work well our
constructions that that I mean it's just
that they also it would be large right
the mr property we can stronger than SD
property in there are constructions that
you can see essentially if you will be
somewhat large but you there are
instances of course that do that the
cool questions coffee with you is Ellis
at this point we don't know watch the
case for SEO to a larger than our three
okay so thanks low